as schools closed buildings boarded up
and small businesses shuttered
tensions rose as the people of kenosha
wisconsin anxiously waited for the jury
to return their verdict in the kyle
ritton house case
to some this was a case of a young man
who took a gun to a protest to defend
himself and his community to others this
was a case of vigilantism and all the
negative connotations that brings
to me it was my wheelhouse under a
microscope the criminal justice system
openly displayed before a nation
this was more than the case of a 17
17-year-old under indictment for
shooting three people
at stake was whether the rule of law and
the rule of self-defense was still
viable and under what circumstances an
individual could legally defend himself
in short the case was a microcosm of the
tensions that had been playing out in
america
the president of the united states
referred to kyle rittenhouse as a white
supremacist
the mainstream media demonized kyle as a
domestic terrorist one who crossed state
lines with an ar-15 a racist and an
active shooter who was looking to kill
and at a time when chaos and anarchy
seemed to rule our streets when black
lives matter members could go about
burning and tearing down businesses with
impunity
many of us felt there was no justice to
be had in america
when ordinary hard-working tax-paying
americans watched marx's socialists and
racists destroy our communities we lost
hope
our anxiety was fueled by the mainstream
media's intent on lying about the facts
and a prosecutor whose own case was
contradicted by his very own star
witness
and by outside protesters with a hearing
range of jurors whose close whose clear
intent was to intimidate the jurors
the question was whether mob justice
could be followed by real justice
the question was whether 12 jurors in a
country so divided could return a
unanimous verdict on all counts
that's the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum read the
jury find the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h ridden house
not guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rose courts we the jury find the
defendant kyle edward kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
kyle rittenhouse's not guilty verdict
changed all that
in the end america watched the criminal
justice system and 12 brave jurors who
recognized their responsibility and the
oath they took
they based their verdict on the law and
the facts
america breathed a sigh of relief
because lady justice was blind to the
claims of the liars and the social
justice warriors and only heard the
facts the law and the evidence thank god
the jurors had the courage the strength
and the integrity to return a verdict
consistent with the truth and thank god
that they reinforced our fundamental
faith in the american criminal justice
system
and that's my open let me know what you
think on my facebook and twitter hashtag
judge janine hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else